[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning it is 7am this is sky news
breakfast it's day 14 of russia's
invasion of ukraine and it's all up in
the air all the promise of another
ceasefire to allow civilians to escape
from besieged cities come good
poland's offer to provide jets for
ukrainian pilots appears to have been
grounded by the united states while it's
now a criminal offence for russian
aircraft to enter uk airspace we'll hear
from the transport secretary grant shaps
shortly it is wednesday the 9th of march
not cleared for takeoff the united
states dismisses poland's plan to
provide fighter jets to ukraine
the red cross says conditions in the
besieged city of marriott apocalyptic
ahead of a new ceasefire to allow
civilians to escape
the victims of war the united nations
says that more than 470 people have died
so far during the conflict
well the sky's the limit it's now a
criminal offence for any russian
aircraft to enter british airspace
the no fry zone at mcdonald's starbucks
and coca-cola join the list of global
brands suspending business in russia
and harmony amongst the horror the
southern city of odessa finds sanctuary
in music
well this is the scene in the ukrainian
capital kiev this morning we'll be live
there for the latest very shortly
also on the programme a little after
nine o'clock following president
vladimir zelinski's historic address to
mps yesterday i'll be joined by the
ukrainian ambassador to the uk
and at a quarter to ten i'll speak with
a renowned neurosurgeon who's been
delivering trauma surgery tutorials to
ukrainian doctors on the front line
[Music]
good morning when president zielenski
renewed his calls for help to ensure the
safety of ukrainian skies he'll have
been buoyed by poland's offer to give
its mig-29 fighter jets to the us to
then pass on to ukraine but late last
night the pentagon said such a move is
untenable and raised concerned for the
nato alliance
well these are the main developments
this morning of the russian invasion of
ukraine russia claims that it's
observing a ceasefire beginning just now
to allow safe passage for civilians
leaving kiev journeyhiv sumi karakiv and
mariopol now it's unclear if the
evacuation routes go through russia or
belarus
ukraine's accused russia of shelling and
evacuation routes that was to take
civilians from mario paul yesterday the
red cross says the situation in the city
is apocalyptic
and the un's human rights office says
it's verified at least
474 civilian deaths so far including 38
children
and in the last hour the uk ministry of
defense says that ukrainian air defenses
have had considerable success against
russian aircraft preventing russia from
getting control of the air greg milam
reports
vova has undergone surgery after being
hit in the head by a bullet
how are you asks the doctor
fine comes the faint reply
this is the children's hospital in
kharkiv a city that's seen some of the
fiercest fighting of this war
eight-year-old dima was hit by shrapnel
when a shell struck the family home it's
lodged at the base of his skull
we have operated on four children
suffering from shrapnel wounds or bullet
wounds
sadly one little girl died yesterday
the staff here continue to work in the
face of regular bombardment and constant
anxiety russia denies targeting
civilians but few in ukraine believe
that
there is some hope for those trying to
escape buses bound for humanitarian
corridors finally able to pass without
being shelled
some from the city of mariopol though
did reportedly come under fire
they leave behind a desperate
situation what their government really
wants is to get their hands on these
polish fighter jets poland happy to send
them but only via the u.s military in
germany
we are ready to give honor of our fleet
of
jet fighters
to ramstein but we are not uh ready to
make any moves on our own because as i
said we are not party uh to this war
it came as news to the americans
within hours the pentagon had killed the
idea it is simply not clear that there
is a substantive rationale for the us or
nato to be flying jets over ukraine it
said
but concerns over being dragged into
this conflict haven't prevented
sanctions again welcomed by ukraine's
president
every cent paid to russia they turn into
bullets and missiles
that are aimed at other sovereign states
but satellite images show the continuing
destruction of his country there is hope
for another humanitarian effort today
but u.s intelligence assessments say
putin has been surprised by the
resistance from ukraine his response
they say will be to escalate this war
greg milam sky news washington
all right let's bring in our special
correspondent alex crawford is joining
us live now from the ukrainian capital
kiev good morning to alex so what's the
latest where you are
well there's still a lot of people
coming out of urban urban is the town
nearest
to the capital it's the west of the
capital it's basically the gateway to
the capital they're still streaming out
they've only just started doing this in
the last hour or so since curfew uh
lifted we know that there are several
hundred maybe thousand people who are
trapped not just in urban but also
butcher and hostimel which are the all
three towns grouped closest to the
capital
this is what the russian troops will
face this is one of the entrances and
you can see they're they're trying to
fortify
um this we're quite we're about half an
hour's drive out of the capital right
now um and uh
that there are a lot more of these
checkpoints and trenches
built as you go into the capital but
they're basically trying to fortify the
capital because we're told that the
russian troops are within
500 meters of uh
coming out of of urban and have taken up
positions so
if they do make it this far and they're
expecting um the inevitable
i think
fairly soon they they're the roads have
all been littered with these spikes to
try and stop the advance the people are
all
who are streaming out now and taking
there's no official
humanitarian corridor in this area but
they are taking advantage of any lull in
fighting um to try and reach safety
which is in the capital right now and
then try and get if they can out of the
capital they've set up
little first aid stations here and you
can see
some of them are obviously um told us
that they've been trapped there for
many many days in european where they've
been under siege
uh they've they're they feel that
they've been troops have been entering
they talk about seeing tanks there's no
food there's no electricity there's no
light there's no water so many of them
felt that they didn't have any choice
but to try and pull out those are the
ones that we've spoken to if they are
if they are injured they're taken to
this first aid tent or if they need
some
sustenance many of them are dehydrated
they haven't had access to food or
anything for many days and then they try
and get buses to go into
the capital many of them heading either
straight to the train station which is
absolutely besieged with people on a
daily basis now just trying to get any
trains that they can any transport that
they can out of the capital
the worry is that the capital itself is
going to be ringed and there's going to
be no escape route from the capital and
a lot of people feeling very worried
about the immediate future kamali okay
alex thank you for that reporting really
appreciate it stay safe thanks for now
all right well the uk government has
made it a criminal offense for any
russian aircraft to enter uk airspace
let's bring in the uh transport
secretary grant chaps who's joining us
now live mr shaps thanks for being with
us on sky news this morning first of all
let's just pick up on uh that line that
the government will now ban russian
aircraft from coming in what does that
actually mean
yeah we've already had a ban of course
on uh russian aircrafts as in aeroflot
the state-owned company and even private
jets or other commercial aircraft what
we're doing now is is going further
we've taken some additional
laws like
powers rather i signed the law late last
night which actually means we'll be able
to be more specific and for example
where we have
aircraft which might be connected with
russian oligarchs
flying into the country they should know
this sends the clearest signal of all uh
you can't do that anymore we can impound
your
aircraft it turns this into a criminal
uh offense and i hope uh sets out this
position very very clearly to them
yeah i mean we're talking a lot about uh
aircraft this morning aren't we mr shap
so peasant zelensky of course wants the
uk to protect ukrainians guys we've had
this discussion overnight about polish
jets being used by the ukrainian air
force where are we with that cause there
seems to be a bit of confusion the u.s
saying that that idea of poland loaning
its mix to the ukrainian air force is
untenable
yeah look i mean actually poland's in
nato we all work to together on this uh
and uh it's important um i think that we
uh are a defensive uh organization uh
which means that uh we won't be getting
directly involved in the uh war
i i as you rightly say the united states
has said that it won't be taking those
uh mig jets that only fly uh make jets
themselves um so that's not uh that's
not something which is going to develop
but make no mistake we're providing huge
amounts of aid and support at the united
kingdom as the first country to provide
anti-tank uh weaponry before this uh war
broke out before ukraine was attacked
as well as training 22 000 ukrainian
troops which is something else the
united kingdom did so we stand fully
behind
ukraine we heard from president um
yesterday in parliament in that
remarkable speech that zelinski gave
with echoes of churchill and we are
doing everything that we possibly can to
support uh our ukrainian friends
yeah so you're saying now that the
british government doesn't support the
idea of poland loaning its migs to the
ukrainian air force
i should say it was nothing to do with
the um british government this is
between
of course we are sorry
of course of course not but as you
mentioned we are part of the nato
alliance and you know that yesterday on
this program the defense secretary said
that it would be entirely up to poland
if they wanted to loan their jets to
ukraine poland say they will loan those
jets so where's the uk government stand
it's but we're not involved in this
particular loan uh idea and the
americans have said that they will not
proceed in that manner
and look i think let me just be
completely up front with you we need to
make sure uh that in uh our
absolutely stringent support for uh
ukraine who are not a nato member of
course we are not inadvertently doing
something uh which escalates uh this war
uh in a way that uh would be uh
unacceptable um to the entire world and
so we're being of course rightly uh
careful and cautious are providing huge
amounts of humanitarian aid providing a
military support as well as you already
heard but not involving ourselves
directly
in the fighting and i think that is
absolutely the right stance
and some may say not providing adequate
refugee support i mean you've seen the
numbers mr shaps you've seen that some
500 visas have been uh accepted 500
visas accepted no idea how many
ukrainians have actually come here
it's shameful isn't it the way that the
uk has held handled this refugee crisis
in europe
760 uh granted now uh 22 000
applications which are on their way
through
look i don't agree with you no country
has given more
assistance to ukraine than the united
kingdom in the world we've given 400
million pounds in addition the british
people have been incredibly generous as
well uh geographically we are of course
spaced further to the west and president
zielinski and the ukrainian government
have told me that they do not want
people to move far away uh if at all
possible in the country because they
want people to be able to come back
having said that we have two schemes
one of which allows up to 200 000
ukrainians here that's the extended
family scheme and it does extend to all
parts of somebody's family aunts and
uncles and that sort of thing and then
of course we've also announced a a
sponsorship route again for those people
without family ties and unlimited so you
know we are we are really leaning into
this at the same time respecting uh
ukraine's wishes the government's wishes
uh not to pull people a long way away
from ukraine which is not something that
they want to see happen but as ever
showing the the the british generosity
particularly in humanitarian support uh
as the largest donor nation
absolutely right lots of money's been
given and lots of people are giving up
uh things for ukrainians but the
geographical thing doesn't quite work
when ireland's taken some 2 000 people
and people in calais are stuck at the
border unable to come in
i think it's right that uh and people
would expect us to be wanting to
check people's status before they come
in we know that russia uh are uh
involved in all sorts of um uh uh
all manner of operations so it's
absolutely right to check that
somebody's come from ukraine know who is
coming to this country um essentially uh
and uh and and that's what we're doing
but we will you know undoubtedly have a
lot of uh ukrainians come here uh to
seek refuge they'll be incredibly
welcomed by the population by the local
authorities by the government we've
shown that huge generosity this country
i mean most people probably don't
realize that over a hundred thousand for
example hong kong chinese have taken up
uh their right of citizenship that we've
granted 25 000 from syria this country
has always been incredibly um generous
but as i said i do want to stress
president zielenski has asked us to
proceed in the way that we are are doing
i i do agree with you with the need to
make sure that there are sufficient
place people to be able to uh access
that visa support
an office in lille has just been set up
uh paris is available i checked last
night uh there are appointments
available uh for people who are who are
making their way west uh but as i say we
we we are no country uh out forms the
united kingdom when it comes to
humanitarian assistance at 400 million
and no other country has provided more
of that assistance so we really can be
proud of what we're doing on the ground
and it it's helped that the ukrainians
are specifically asking us to provide as
well yeah i mean on that mr did at the
home secretary preacher patel mislead
parliament when she said that there was
a visa center set up in calais she said
it twice and there isn't one
so there's visa assistance in in calais
i know so there are there are british
officials
where you can take biometrics
and those kind of details that are
necessary if people to pass the visa
requirements to get into the country
yeah look i i didn't hit the specific
comment but i do know that in little uh
there is a center being set up uh i do
also know that because of the nature of
the situation in calais of course very
long-term uh issues there of um criminal
gangs bringing people across we're very
keen to separate these two issues so
that people don't get involved or caught
up
in some of that and on their way
towards the united kingdom if they're
coming here particularly for those
family schemes or later for the
sponsorship schemes we want to make sure
that people can have been
processed via the visa application
centers we've got six thousand it has
been massively expanded usually the i
think about 800 slots will be available
we've got six thousand slots available
uh now for people um who are seeking
those um visas uh and uh you know i
think it's very important that britain
does throw its arms around and try to
assist but i do want to stress that
president zielinski has directly asked
us uh for the humanitarian provision and
doesn't want people broadly speaking
unless they have those family ties but
broadly speaking would prefer people to
settle uh closer uh to ukraine because
we want people he wants people uh to go
back again uh which is very important
when it comes to rebuilding this country
and post war
no absolutely right we will listen to
what president zielenski has to say
because of course you want people close
by to the country but you said you
didn't hear the home secrets yesterday
i'll tell you what she said she said
that there's a visa center set up in
calais uh sarajegal says that that's not
true and if you've lied to parliament
it's a resigning matter do you agree
i don't know i i i i didn't hear the
comments although except what you're
saying to me uh i do know
yeah sure i do know there's a visa
center in in lille
and i know that there are a number of
centers as people travel uh west there
are also people assisting
in calais in order to help provide
people with direction and information i
do just stress that point that what we
don't want to do is see people fleeing
ukraine caught up with what has been
know very much is a you know criminal uh
people trafficking uh operation that
runs out of calais uh which uh is
something we certainly don't want people
escaping war to then get caught up in so
what we encourage everybody to do is to
use one of the 24-hour phone numbers uh
arrange for the uh for to see what to
see somebody through one of those 6 000
now
visa appointments which are available
and
and take up one of the routes as i say
we've got very very i've seen this
reported a lot and it's slightly
mystifying we've got very very generous
program in place and further programs
coming along the program for the
extended family for example could see
two hundred thousand ukrainians come
here the sponsorship scheme again will
be uh unlimited uh when that's when
that's launched and uh you know i think
i think it's uh you know tribute to the
british people the amount of uh help and
assistance
people have been giving and this country
has provided more humanitarian support
by the government plus in addition to
what people have private being given
than any other country okay mr jackson
finally then quickly if you can please
uh appreciate all of that but some
people will say that they need more help
to get to this country but we'll move on
quickly to the news overnight that the
uk us i knew you were going to phase out
the use of russian oil and gas where's
the uk going to get its energy from if
it stops using russian surprises
yeah sure i should point out the uk
doesn't buy for example petrol none of
our petrol comes from um russia we do
have some um some some gas and some
diesel uh as you point out look
my view is quite simple we we need to
stem the flow of putin's gas and oil
blood money from funding his war machine
and i think that the british people
even
though it will of course lead to some
higher energy uh prices although we've
probably already seen uh that as a
happening already the british people are
not prepared to see us funding uh
putin's horrific war
and so i think it's very very important
that we
take this step uh we will step up our
own production and we're fortunate in
the uk that we don't buy uh
proportionately very much uh russian oil
and gas and we do also produce our own
so we'll step that up as well but i
think it's incredibly important that we
do this because uh we must not be uh
providing the blood money to fund his
war
mr shabs okay grant shabs uk
transportation thank you very much for
your time thank you
thank you
all right let's take a look now how the
newspapers are covering the crisis in
ukraine this morning the ft leads with
the u.s government's banning of russian
oil imports and also mentions the uk's
decision to do the same
the metro reacts to the speech given to
the house of commons by ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky with the
headline hear hear
hero
the telegraph leads with the offer from
poland to supply ukraine with mig
fighter jets mig-29s we just talked
about the transport secretary to deal
with the russian air force over ukraine
well the times has that story too
pointing out that it's risking even
greater confrontation between nato
countries and russia
while the
daily star has an interview with the uh
former ukrainian boxing champion
vladimir klitschko who is now the mayor
of kiev as you'll known as defending in
his country what he calls the biggest
fight of his life
now with russia promising to observe a
ceasefire to let civilians flee some of
the major cities let's take a look at
the latest developments all across the
country well the capital woke up to air
raid sirens this morning no reports of
shelling there yet we'll get the latest
from our correspondent alex crawford uh
karakiv chennai sumi and mario paul are
all surrounded by the russians and
continue to see heavy shelling there now
80 miles west of the capital kiev at
least five people have been killed when
bombs destroyed a textile factory in
zotomy in bonodanka local officials say
that heavy shelling is making it
impossible to remove the bodies of some
12 people who died in a hospital where
200 patients were stuck without food and
medicine
and in karaki of two people including a
seven-year-old were killed in a bombing
the regional governor also claimed that
the russian attempt to enter that city
had been beaten back
now 90 miles away in sumi authorities
were able to evacuate 5 000 people
yesterday that's according to ukraine's
deputy prime minister but russian forces
continue to surround the southern city
of mario pole where residents have been
without water and electricity and bodies
lay uncollected in the streets the red
cross describes the situation there as
apocalyptic
let's take a look at some other stories
emerging from the crisis now and the
united nations human rights office says
that it's verified
474 civilian deaths and 861 injuries in
ukraine since the russian invasion began
at the end of february with the real
death toll likely to be much higher
the un have also said that more than 2
million refugees have fled since the
start of russia's military offensive in
the uk the home office announced the
number of visas had risen to 760s we
heard from the transport secretary just
now while a new processing center is to
be set up in lille
expected to be ready to go within the
next 24 hours
and the new end's nuclear watchdog says
it's lost contact with systems
monitoring radioactive material at
chernobyl the radiation levels there
initially spiked when russian forces
took over nearly two weeks ago but
experts say another disaster is
extremely unlikely
well the musician bob goldoff is among
several musicians taking part in the
concerts to raise money for ukraine the
event will be held at the roundhouse in
north london and features imelda may
organizers hope to raise vital funds for
people who are fleeing the fighting
mcdonald's starbucks and coca-cola are
just a handful of the latest western
companies to halt their operations in
russia bowing to pressure over sanctions
they join the likes of microsoft ikea
and netflix in pulling out following the
invasion of ukraine
well sherman freeman powell has more on
this story for us and joins us now live
from the newsroom shiman good morning to
you so mcdonald's have decided to pull
out it's a no-fry zone some are saying
yes it has been dubbed a no fry zone
these are all major companies that have
operations in russia and have all said
that they will no longer be operating
there and then the last few moments
we've also heard from mother care who
also says that there will be ceasing
trade there too and this is very
significant particularly for pepsi and
mcdonald's decades ago the fact that
they were prepared to work under the
soviet union and post-soviet russia had
been recognised for developing
international relations but for now at
least temporarily those international
relations have come to an end mcdonald's
pepsi coca-cola starbucks have all
announced they will stop selling their
products in russia mcdonald's say it
will close
847 of its stores but will continue to
pay 62 000 of its employees that work
there also starbucks say it will stop
operating its business in the country
too which includes any shipments of its
products to russia and it will also
close more than 100 of its stores as
well sky news did speak to the chief
executive of starbucks kevin johnson who
said we condemn the horrific attacks on
ukraine by russia and our heart goes out
to all those affected we have decided to
suspend all business in activity in
russia including shipment of all
starbucks products and this is the
latest move from the west showing a
united front and attempting to isolate
russia economically for what's happening
in ukraine but we must remember that
companies and governments and
individuals for the past few weeks have
all been sanctioning and cutting ties
with russia with companies like apple
netflix and h m all taking a stand but
these companies starbucks mcdonald's
pepsi and coca-cola had faced criticism
of the past few days thousands had taken
to social media calling for customers to
boycott these companies for sitting on
the fence and it seems that they have
listened and as i say in the last few
moments mother care also have said that
they will be suspending its trading in
russia too so it seems that many more
companies will be following their lead
okay shiman for now thank you
well new nighttime satellite pictures
from nasa show how the lights have gone
out all across ukraine this timeline
shows how ukrainian cities have gone
dark since russia's invasion nearly two
weeks ago a stark contrast with
neighboring states poland to the west
and of course russia to the east the
likes of moscow are clearly visible
there
at the top of your screen
well still to come on sky news breakfast
as the humanitarian crisis in ukraine
worsens the transport station tells this
programme the uk will not get involved
in any decision to provide ukraine with
fighter jets
[Music]
i am there to speak truth to power one
question to ask questions that people
want to answer
when i'm interviewing a politician it's
a more rapid fire but this is not this
is a conversation the format of the show
so we're going to have an hour-long
interview show once a week on a thursday
night it's at 9pm it's a moment to press
pause on this frenetic pace of news and
just reflect on things and when we do
have a politician on the show you might
see them interviewed by me in a
different way than you perhaps normally
see it what they do
why they do it if i can find some of
that and bring it onto sky news i'd be
really happy
hello and welcome back you're watching
sky news breakfast our top stories this
morning the united states has dismissed
poland's plan to provide fighter jets to
ukraine calling the proposals not
tenable
the latest intelligence from the uk's
ministry of defense identifies ongoing
fighting in the northwest of kiev with a
number of cities including mario paul
and sumi encircled and suffering heavy
shelling
and the united kingdom has imposed new
sanctions on russia making it a criminal
offence for any russian aircraft to
enter british airspace
well the united states has dismissed
poland's plan to provide fighter jets to
ukraine calling the proposals not
tenable the transport secretary grant
shaps told me earlier that the uk will
not get get involved in any such
proposals
well i should say it was nothing to do
with the um british government this is
between the polish and the americans
you've heard what both sides have said
on this but we're not involved in this
particular loan uh idea and the
americans have said that they will not
proceed in that manner
and look i think let me just be
completely up front view we need to make
sure
that in
our
absolutely stringent support for uh
ukraine who are not a nato member of
course we are not inadvertently doing
something uh which escalates uh this war
i'm pleased to see our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen joins us
now live so tomorrow i wasn't dreaming
this day ben wallis kind of left it open
for this to happen there was lots of
talk about it overnight but grandchild
was making it quite clear that this idea
of providing jets to the ukrainian air
force is just not going to happen well
this was not something the uk was
actually involved in at all this was an
idea that the polish government would
send some of their mig-29s to ukraine
and then the americans got involved
saying that they might then replace the
polish fleet now the polls always
thought that this was incredibly high
risk for them to do on their own as ben
wallace set out to us yesterday saying
they took the risk of russia deciding to
escalate this and see this as a nato
member joining the war now
even a week ago this looked very tricky
and i understand that boris johnson has
been involved in these discussions he
talked to the polish prime minister
about it when he was there last week he
talked to the leaders of other countries
in the region who were in london
yesterday he apparently refers to it as
renter migs now the uk as always i'm
told thought this was going to be very
difficult to achieve without escalating
things into world war iii frankly and it
sounds as if the americans are now of
that view as well pretty much wants a
better word shooting down the proposal
overnight and it now looks like it's not
going to be able to go ahead although
everyone wants to do everything they can
to help the ukrainians it really does
sound like from the uk's point of view
that this is not something that's really
likely to work no it's not going to be
the way to close the ukrainian skies for
now all right tomorrow thank you very
much
now over 1.2 million people have fled
ukraine into neighboring poland since
the start of russia's invasion now one
of those is someone we were able to
speak to last week on sky news stuart
mckenzie is a brit who left ukraine with
his ukrainian wife he's joining us now
from krakov in poland stuart good
morning to you uh pleased to be able to
speak with you again it wasn't me i
spoke to you last time but thanks for
being back on sky news uh just tell us
what's the situation with you now uh and
your wife are you able to come to the uk
when you want to
uh well we know there's lots of problems
with uh visas do they get to the uk at
the moment my mother-in-law
who's elderly who doesn't have an
international passport we will be stuck
and i don't want to be stuck in cali or
other places we've rented a house in
poland like many ukrainians they don't
want to
go far from from ukraine we want to stay
close to our homes too close to our
families etc hoping hoping that we'll be
able to go back
soon
um but i'm not going to take my
mother-in-law the stress of getting
trying to get into the uk
um without
with the news reports i'm seeing at the
moment it's better for us to stay here
we've rented a house we're getting all
my staff members and friends everybody's
helping everybody trying to get over the
border and get accommodation when
they're here there's of course charities
but there's also you know the rentals
people are asking for one month's rent
one month's deposit one month's final
and these are people you know the
purchase power of the local grievance
when they come over is is very small for
where it was
and that's very difficult for people so
you know we're constantly putting people
in their house sheltering them for a few
days until we can find other
accommodation um but yeah
we're not certainly gonna
right now the situation of trying to get
into the uk
under the the the problems that they're
having is not what we're going to do
yeah i mean
we'll come on to talk a little bit more
about the effort that everyone's sort of
putting in to help those who are fleeing
but just on this uh access to the uk so
your wife is able to come with you that
should be no problem but it's now your
mother-in-law and you're saying you're
getting your information from news
reports the the home office aren't
giving you details as to what you need
to do
it's it's it's not what i n you know we
will get to that point i think right now
if we chose to leave from krakow and get
to the uk
and the news reports and also personal
reports that i've heard about you know
having them to go back to different
places to get different visas and having
to take my mother-in-law through that
whole journey is not she's not
physically capable of doing that at the
moment and we're not going to put her
through that stress of what we've
already been through on top so what i
want to do is stay here safe get the
family in a routine and then start that
process my wife
i've been married for 25 years she's oh
she's got a ukrainian passport my three
children got british passports she's
always had visas but we didn't she's not
got a visa for the uk right now because
of covert we just let it run out um
she'll always get a visa that's never a
problem but we still have to go through
that process
um so
you know we're safe in poland
and uh and we'll we'll start that
when i start to see better reports of
how easier i can make it for my
mother-in-law if indeed we wanted to go
back to the uk are still the number one
thing is hoping that we can get back to
ukraine yeah you all just want to go
home back to ukraine and you mentioned a
little bit at stuart earlier about the
effort that people are putting in once
they've managed to escape the war zone
you said that you're opening up the home
that you've rented to people who are
crossing the border is that something
that's quite common that everyone there
is just kind of pushing in to make sure
that everyone gets all the help they
need
most definitely and not just here in
ukraine uh any i'll speak to my
financial manager who can't leave i mean
remember the people i'm putting up in my
house
um
i'm women with children
and they've got little money and their
husbands can't get out so not only did
you have to leave
two weeks ago a normal life where you
had a home and school and friends and
family not only did you have to make a
big decision to leave that under bombing
and the war but then you had to get to
the border with your husband and then
leave your husband behind
and and children so we're putting up
with women you know we're putting women
up here with their with their their
children and it's heartbreaking when you
see them on the phone at night saying hi
daddy this is where i'm sleeping tonight
don't you know it's it's just that it's
just a nightmare of all situations but
what i'm trying to do then is speak to
the husbands say don't worry about your
family don't worry about your children
we've got them we've sheltered them um
you worry about yourself
and
they're here now you've got them across
the body you've done a great job in
doing that now leave it to us to look
after them and make sure that daddy
comes home
okay absolutely right uh stuart
mackenzie thank you very much for now
let's bring in uh jeff vinol now he's an
american who also uh fled ukraine with
his wife
uh jeff good morning to you i believe
you know stu you met him in a hotel when
you guys managed to get out of the
country just tell us what's your
situation right now how are you and your
family
uh we're doing really
okay right now in the sense that um
we have a place to stay uh and uh we're
safe
as far as my family goes um
you know
there's a huge tank battle going on in
their neighborhood it's been raging for
three days we're in and out of contact
with them and um you know we don't know
about their safety on a day-to-day basis
and that's extremely scary uh we have a
lot of people inside uh
ukraine that were contacting at all
times trying trying to move around
let them know any information that we
have and um
so basically from the time i wake up
till the time i go to bed i'm i'm doing
everything i can to help
my wife is also volunteering at an aid
station here and she gets up every day
and goes and does that you know
gathering supplies we've greeted people
at the train station and things like
that
you said your family you're sort of cut
off surrounded by tank battle
whereabouts in ukraine are they
i'm they're uh
they're uh about 50 kilometers outside
of kiev and it just so happens that the
village that they're staying is is
apparently some sort of key point
uh
professional
um uh two weeks ago i was teaching kids
how to hold a seven iron i'm in the pga
of ukraine
uh and now everyone in my organization
the pga of ukraine uh is is now holding
a weapon in their hometown getting ready
to defend their territory
and i'm trying everything i can to you
know get um
information to them the golf course
where i work is currently a staging
ground for russian paratroopers uh and
it's been shelled and and and and i feel
that
uh you know that um
uh you know uh
the the guys in my organization are have
gone from being golf pros to fighters
overnight and the women in our
organization are helping relief they may
be holding weapons too ukrainian women
hold weapons in their hometowns
so um
i'm doing everything i can to support my
organization because i know they're
they're they're helping
they're also getting people to safety
they're doing a lot of things this is
the pga of ukraine
um and um i'm wearing my shirt now my
pga of ukraine shirt i tried to get some
fundraising organizations going i tried
gofundme i tried everything that i could
to get some money to them to to help
them
they need bulletproof vests they need
helmets they need all kinds of things
these are not professional soldiers
they're golf pros
um and if i could just for a moment i'd
like to
to say to my fellow golf pros out there
and i'm not just talking you know lee
westwood ian poulter tiger woods i'm
talking anybody out there who plays golf
who who um
who wants to help us you can follow me
at um
pga ukraine i'm on twitter
and i'm trying to find a secure bank
account something that i can do the
traditional fundraising methods have
failed me
and so uh
you know i know that we're getting uh
people out of harm's way and we're doing
everything we can to help in ukraine
but it's a helpless feeling to be
outside the country
and know that you can help people inside
the country and there's just these um
i don't know how to say it just these
kind of like brick walls in between
uh trying to find a way to raise money
and and get it directly to people who
are doing really important work inside
the country
definitely jeff vino i hope that people
are listening and will uh
hear your plea and provide you just give
us your
online account again just quickly if
they want to use it
uh well i'm at twitter
uh at pga of ukraine or pga ukraine
um and i'm gonna be you know updating
information if there's anybody that can
help me with a secure link
so that we can raise money to get to the
pga of ukraine to to to protect my
brothers and sisters who are golf
professionals who are now soldiers and
and relief workers
um
then please uh uh do help try to help us
because um
okay um
this is a life or death situation and uh
none of us we all just want to go back
to golf you know what i mean we all just
want to go back to
living our lives and feeding our
families and enjoying our beautiful
country i'm not going back to america
jeff a lot of people have asked me sorry
to interrupt you jeff sorry we've we've
just run so short of time everyone's
heard your plea and i'm sure thank you
very much those who can help no no thank
you uh for all your you're doing thank
you jeffernell there uh in uh krakow
who's fled ukraine now the home office
is being accused of dirty propaganda
after appearing to suggest that islands
welcome to ukrainian refugees posed a
security threat to the uk well dublin's
joined the rest of the eu in waiving
visa rules and is expected to admit as
many as a hundred thousand people
fleeing from invasion our island
correspondent steven murphy reports
putting back the pieces of family life
surrounded by newly donated toys ivan
ihor and lisa and their mother hannah
are adjusting to new surroundings in
ireland
the family fled kiev after the russian
invasion they were taken in by an old
ukrainian friend pavlo who lives in the
dublin suburbs
is
hannah's husband andre is allowed to
leave ukraine as he's a father of three
and will join his family in ireland soon
a beneficiary of visa requirements being
scrapped
ukrainian families have been reunited
here in their hundreds
the steady stream of ukrainians here at
dublin airport continues they say
they're grateful that ireland has
dropped the visa requirements but
they're also honest they don't want to
be here
lubov arrived on a flight from poland
collected by her brother vasil she's a
reluctant arrival they hope to come back
to home but
at the moment you know everything is
it's
kind of like disaster there
hannah too is adamant that their stay
here will be temporary is the future
going to be here or is the future back
in ukraine
ireland will never be their home but it
is for now at least their haven
stephen murphy sky news dublin
now and amidst the horrors of the war uh
musical interleave now
well the video here that you're watching
was released by ukraine's ministry of
defense it shows a as you can see a
military band playing outside the opera
and ballet house in odessa the city so
far escaped shelling but it is in the
sights of the russians
we'll still to come on sky news
breakfast
we'll take a closer look at how europe
has responded to russia's invasion
[Music]
hello and welcome back now much of
europe has already imposed significant
sanctions on russia and tougher measures
are still on the cards well let's uh
talk now through the european response
with rafael los he's from the european
council on foreign relations good
morning to you rafael thanks for being
with us so just describe how you think
europe has handled this crisis on his
eastern border
look i think um in the weeks leading up
to russia's attack on ukraine um
europeans european leaders
and with transatlantic partners
have sought to communicate to vladimir
putin the russian president that he any
attack would have severe consequences in
the political and economic but also in
the specific realm and this message
clearly hasn't sunk in with putin he was
not deterred by this prospect of
significant sanctions and so we're now
um looking at how sanctions can be used
as a tool to compel
um russian armed forces to to
de-escalate and to nudge vladimir putin
to take one of the off-ramps that have
been offered to de-escalate the crisis
and to um spare lives in ukraine
i mean this is the banks not tanks isn't
it raphael but we're kind of some would
say that we're past that moment now and
and you know that there has long been
talk of some kind of european army if
that was in place do you think you would
have behaved like this putin
i suspect that a european army is not
really the answer to this to this to
this challenge that putin poses and it's
really tanks and banks and that we're
seeing sort of on the move now we see
nato countries reinforcing their posture
on the on the eastern flag of the
alliance they've nato leaders have long
made clear that they wouldn't send
troops into ukraine to fight alongside
ukraine's army against the russian
attackers
but there are certainly
measures that be that are being taken
and we've we've seen significant numbers
of anti-tank weapons and anti-aircraft
missiles being brought into ukraine and
and those have um shown some successes
against um advancing russian forces and
it's really critical for ukraine's army
and for the ukrainian resistance to to
have a steady supply of ammunitions of
fuels of other military supplies to keep
up their um defensive fight for ukraine
uh raphael i thought then on the
humanitarian response we've seen many
european countries open their borders to
ukrainian refugees and of course there
is a war going on on the continent but
it does seem stark when compared to
other refugee crisis in the in recent
years and the way that some european
countries have been putting up fences
uh it is really remarkable um we see a
lot of countries in in the immediate
vicinity of ukraine accepting tremendous
numbers of refugees um those income
countries that are both within the eu so
if you look at um poland and hungary for
instance accepting significant numbers
but also countries like moldova and that
have not um had the benefit of being
part of the european union of being
integrated into an economic and
legal framework that that would allow
for sort of moving refugees from there
quickly into other european countries to
lessen the burden on moldova um and so
this raises questions how europeans um
within the eu framework but also
other partners like uk and the united
states government
can support um countries in in ukraine's
neighborhood to lessen the pressure on
them but i think you're right to point
out that it's remarkable and remarkably
inconsistent how some europeans have
responded to this crisis compared to
previous refugees crises um if we just
remember 2015 or so um um
syrian refugees arriving um in europe um
germany opens its tourism and some other
countries were less um welcoming to them
right okay uh rafael los from the
european council on foreign relations
thank you very much for your time this
morning
thank you for having me
well still to come on at sky news
breakfast we'll have all the very latest
from ukraine this is the capital kiev
this morning just 5 to 10 in the morning
as russian forces continue to encircle
the city
forcing the ukrainians to defend their
land and their people against a russian
invasion we'll have the very latest from
our reporting on ground alex corporado
is just outside of kiev in european
coming up in the next hour and i'll also
be speaking to the labour shadow home
secretary ivette cooper to talk about
what labour would be doing if they were
in charge of the current refugee crisis
all that to come after the break stay
with us
[Music]